previously on hunter x hunter gong left
his village to walk in his father's
footsteps while trying to pass the
hunter exams he meets leorio karapika
and kiluah
on the final phase of exam everyone gets
their hunter license expect kiluah who
gets disqualified due to his brother
interference gon finally finds kalua
after passing through some difficult
tests and heads to the butler's quarters
the story continues after kilua's father
sets him free he heads to the butler's
quarters the same place where gon and
the others are heading
kiliwa arrives at the quarters and
orders goto to call him just as gone
arrives after a while the three arrive
at the quarters being welcomed by the
butlers gutto tells them that kiluah is
on his way they play a game of coin
guessing where they will need to guess
which hand is google holding the coin
he also states that they only have three
seconds to answer
gutto tosses a coin in the air juggles
it and catches it the oreo gives the
wrong guess and eventually coropika as
well the only one left is gon when
governor was about to toss the coin gone
requests for a knife to cut his swollen
eye in order to minimize the swelling to
improve his vision after that goto uses
the same procedure by tossing the coin
and catching it with amazing hand speed
but gone is able to find the correct
hand that contains the coin
in the final round goto and two other
butlers join him tossing the coin
incredibly fast and adding multiple
hands to increase the difficulty goto
asks him which butler has the coin gohan
answers confidently and points out that
the butler behind him has it
keluwa enters the room and rejoins gon
kurapika and leorio and bids farewell to
the butlers and canary
kilauea asks gon why he's not using his
hunter license gon explains he needs to
pay the debts he has for the people
who've helped him including returning
hisoka's badge and then he will use his
hunter license however gon doesn't know
the location of hisoka but kurapika
admits he does and reveals to his
friends the message hisoka whispered to
him during their match in the final
phase of the hunter exam
he tells them that hisoka will likely
show up at york new city including the
group who massacred the kurta clan the
phantom troupe
after the discussion korapica bids
farewell to his friends to look for a
job as a hunter followed by leorio who
also bids goodbye to study and become a
doctor but before totally parting ways
the group decides to meet on september
1st at york new city and so the two
decided to go to their next destination
where they can train and at the same
time earn money in heaven's arena
traveling by airship going spots the
enormous tower and kaluar reveals that
it's called heaven's arena adding that
it has 251 floors and is 991 meters tall
the two plan to register for the
tournament to earn money while training
at the same time gonna surprise by the
long line akilua explains that unlike
the hunter exam heaven's arena doesn't
have any conditions to participate
besides defeating one's opponent
after registering the two enter a
crowded arena and wait until their
numbers are called
gouton asks him if he's been there
before and kilua replies that he
competed when he was only six after his
father left him there with no money and
told him to reach the 200th floor before
returning home
he reveals that it took him two years to
do so kiluah then tells gom that if he
wants to fight opponents of hisoka's
level he will need to reach the higher
floors of the tower
gone's number is called and he nervously
prepares to fight gon enters the ring
and looks across at his enormous
opponent as the referee explains the
rules and begins the match the large man
promises to end things with a single
punch but gone easily dodges the attack
and uses a simple palm strike just as
kiluah instructed him sending the man
flying into the wall behind him
as gon looks at his hand and wonders
when he became so strong the referee
gives him a ticket and tells him that he
can make his way to the 50th floor
after easily defeating his opponent as
well kalua is told that he can go to the
180th floor since he has reached the 204
before but he politely declines and
decides to start at the 50th floor with
gone beside kiluah another young boy
easily wins his match and also prepares
to make his way to the 50th floor
as the three make their way to the 50th
floor an elevator attendant explains how
moving up the tower works and the boy
adds that he has heard they will get
their own room if they make it to the
100th floor introducing himself as zushi
zushi's master suddenly appears and
praises his student for following his
teachings zushi's master introduces
himself as wing and tells them that he
didn't expect to see other children
wondering why they are there killua
tells him that they hope to get stronger
and make money
the three boys then head to a nearby
kiosk and receive their prize money
kiluah immediately buys a canned drink
with the money and reveals that a win in
the 50s has a reward of 50 000
he then adds that wins in the 100s are
worth a million and any wins past the
154 are worth 10 million each
the three that make their way to a
crowded waiting room to prepare for
their next match it suddenly announced
that kalua and zushi will fight each
other on the 57th floor the announcer
introduces the two fighters the odds are
in zurshi's favor and killua is left
frustrated by the result the referee
then explains the rules and begins the
match although impressed by zushi's
fighting stance killua calmly walks
toward him and avoids his punch before
swiftly striking the back of his neck
kiluah earns two points for the strike
as the referee checks on zushi who
suddenly rises to his feet and leaves
kilua surprised
zushi unleashes a barrage of punches but
kalua easily dodges them all and again
strikes the back of his neck zushi
recovers again and decides to resort to
a new stance that leaves kilua terrified
and causes him to quickly leak back
watching among the crowd wing suddenly
screams zushi's name and causes the
spectators around him to put their hands
over their ears he sits down with a
stern expression on his face and zushi
appears visibly shaken before the
announcer restarts the match
kelulah eventually meets up with gon who
was wondering what took him so long
killua tells him that zushi wasn't
strong he then reveals that zushi's aura
during his new stance reminded him of
his brothers oblivious to what it was
but confident that it's dangerous he
guesses that it's a technique and tells
gone that wing called it ren in a
flashback killua sees zushi on his hands
and knees apologizing to wing who
reminds him that he wasn't supposed to
use ren yet zushi says that he couldn't
resist against such a strong opponent
and wing tells him that while wanting to
win is good he needs to remember his
true goal of reaching the top four
back in the present gone wonders if
sushi isn't supposed to use ren until
reaching the top floor and kilua reveals
that he now plans to reach the top floor
as well with gon happily agreeing and
telling himself that it was his original
goal anyway gon and killua continue to
easily defeat all their opponents over
the next few days with both reaching the
100s they each receive a private room
and while gone is happy that they don't
have to worry about finding a place
killua points out that if they drop
below the 100s they have to check out it
mourns going that the competition will
become more difficult since every
opponent wants to keep their spot
however the two continue to easily win
and receive more prize money with both
noting that sushi is still in the 50s
gon again wonders about the technique
called ren
and while kilua thinks about
encountering it with opponents on the
higher fours gown suggests simply asking
zushi about it the two do just that and
zushi explains that it's one of the four
major principles for training one's mind
and body he adds that one must know 10
learn zetsu achieve ren and reach hatsu
which are all part of men training
as killua angrily points out that he
didn't understand any of what he said
wing suddenly appears and wonders if
sushi should be teaching them kilulat
tells him that he is eager to know what
it is since it's connected to the secret
of his brother's power wing asks if his
brother is able to use men but kalua
points out that he doesn't even know
what nen and ren mean agreeing to go
through the complete learning process
wing tells the two to join him in zushi
at his house as they prepare to learn
about the secret technique of men wing
teaches gon kilua
in his room he explains the four main
principles
ten
zetsu ren and hatsu or focus express
temper and act respectively
wing tells kiluah he'll think about
killing him he demonstrates ten by
focusing his body zetsu by saying the
words i'll kill you
and ren by giving off a strong aura of
an intent to kill
because of the strong pressure kalua
jumps back hanging on the ceiling corner
of the room
wing advises them to train with sushi
and start mastering 10 but kilua
suggests that they should leave kiluau
reveals to gon that wing was lying all
alone back in the room wing notices
zushi's tent is unstable sushi asks
about the reason as to why wing lied to
them wing only said that for them to
know what the other meaning of men is
force wayne rips out a page in a book
and using men on it easily slices his
soda can in half
wing's point is it's dangerous to teach
nen to people without caution
after clearing the 190th floor gone and
killua advance to the 200th floor they
are stopped by a strong aura of a
murderous intent which prevents them
from moving forward they barely get
through it as the receptionist appears
stating that they need to register
before midnight hisoka appears out of
nowhere in front of the two behind the
receptionist and warns them that they
are not ready yet he prevents gon and
killua from progressing with powerful
men
wing appears behind them to stop them
from hurting themselves and offers to
teach them the real men in wing's room
gon and killua are finally taught the
real nine at his residence wing tells
gohan and killua that they must learn
men to protect themselves from other nen
users explaining that they must use ten
for defense
to demonstrate how destructive nan can
be to the human body he puts his hand
against one of the room's walls and
suddenly damages it leaving gohan and
kilua stunned
wing's lesson continues into the night
and it stated that gohan and killua must
learn men before midnight wayne reveals
that while the power of nen dwells
within every person only a few are
capable of using it and are considered
geniuses psychics superhumans etc he
explains that there are two ways to
awaken the power deliberately or
aggressively
with zushi having used the former he
adds that zushi learned quickly and
trained hard allowing him to master 10
in six months kilua quickly reminds him
that they need to learn 10 and pass
through hisoka's barrier before midnight
wing tells them that they will have to
try the aggressive method and killua
wonders if it will be fast enough
after explaining that the key is
learning to contain their aura within
their bodies
wing tells the two that he will now
direct his aura toward them known as
hatsu the same technique that he used to
destroy the wall
wing assures them that he will restrain
himself so he doesn't destroy their
bodies however he warns them that the
process of forcing open a person's aura
nodes is dangerous since it usually
takes months for someone to slowly open
the nodes on their own he then tells
them to put down their belongings take
off their over shirts and turn their
backs toward him
they follow these instructions and wing
holds his hands near both of their backs
with the two immediately feeling the
heat and pressure as kilulat is reminded
of illumi's men although a much weaker
version wing begins the process and
sends his aura through both their bodies
successfully opening all their aura
nodes as a strange substance flows from
them both wing explains that it's their
aura life energy
wing tells them that they will become
tired if enough escapes and eventually
collapse from fatigue if they expend all
of it he quickly gets their attention
and tells them to concentrate on
containing the aura within their bodies
asking them to close their eyes
visualize the aura flowing like blood
through them and picture it hovering
around their bodies
the two immediately master the technique
leaving zushi stunned and wing in awe as
he says to himself that they are
incredible for realizing the most
effective stance without meaning to be
told wing tells them to slowly open
their eyes and gon describes the
sensation as being surrounded by warm
mucus with kulua saying that he feels
like he's wearing weightless clothes
wing tells them to remember the feeling
and that they will eventually be able to
use ten while sleeping he then suddenly
prepares to use hostile men against them
explaining that it would have been too
painful for them to withstand it before
back on the 200th floor gon and killua
appear before hisoka who quickly sends
out his nan toward them however with
both now using ten they confidently walk
toward him and easily pass through his
barrier ahsoka dispels his nan and
welcomes them to the 200s guessing that
gon came to heaven's arena to train
before challenging him
gon replies that he didn't expect to
find hisoka there and that it saves him
time causing hisoka to chuckle and tell
gone that he shouldn't become too
confident now that he can use ten
he reveals that they have much more to
learn about nen holding up two fingers
and creating various shapes using his
aura he tells gun that while he
currently has no desire to fight him he
will agree to a match if he is able to
win even once in the 200s
after hisoka walks away three other
fighters watch the two boys and see that
they are able to use nen a female clerk
happily welcomes the two to the 200s and
asks them to fill out the necessary
forms wondering if they would also like
to register for a match
she also reveals that they need 10 wins
to clear the floor and then if they lose
4 matches before then they will also be
disqualified
she then excitedly reveals that if they
win 10 matches they will have the chance
to fight the four masters the 21
strongest fighters at heaven's arena who
control floors 230-250
she adds that they will become the new
master of the floor and be able to
participate in the battle olympia
tournament if they defeat its current
owner
gohan and killua are left unimpressed by
the explanation with the latter
wondering if the top floor has anything
special the clerk angrily explains that
the winner of battle olympia gets to
live in the penthouse at the top of the
tower but gone points out that kilauea's
house is three thousand seven hundred
meters above ground as gonn fills out
the necessary form the three fighters
approach the two boys and reveal that
they are simply waiting to register
killulah realizes that they want to
fight on the same day as gon the two
suddenly notice a message on the
television stating that gohan's fight
will take place at 3 p.m on march 11 and
kiluua can't believe that it's already
been scheduled for the next day
on the day of the match the announcer
introduces gon first and then his
opponent guido
in a flashback wing tells goman kiluah
that 10 is used only for defense and
reminds the two that they have not
worked on their offense at all he also
warns them that a highly skilled nen
user will be able to break through their
tent to deal a possibly lethal strike
asking that they both wait at least two
months before their first match and
offering to teach them as much as
possible during that time
back in the present gone apologizes to
wing and smiles as he tells himself that
he's just too eager to fight
as zushi watches with a smile on his
face wing is left exasperated by gone's
decision to fight so soon
the referee begins the match and gohan
immediately uses ten
gitover chuckles in reply and suddenly
reveals several spinning tops that move
along his walking stick
as the announcer calls on his dancing
tops guido uses his battle wallet's
ability and sends them flying toward
goan
the top spin all around him and bounce
into each other with one suddenly
striking him in the back gone quickly
recovers and jitto is given one point
for a clean hit gone dodges multiple
tops and is left worried since each one
hits as hard as a hammer nervously
waiting for another to strike
his ten also gradually begins to fade a
hit from a top sends him outside the
ring go notices atop not attacking him
outside the ring he then understands
that the tops simply attack anything
getting in their way and gets an idea to
attack guido while ignoring the tops but
gone fails because gido uses another nan
ability called tornado top due to
gohan's willingness to fight he conceals
his presence without knowing it with
zetsu one of the four main principles of
nen wing is amazed but can't stop
worrying about gone's situation
as the fight resumes gon dodges all of
giro's tops for a certain period of time
but eventually is worn by kilua and ends
up in a no escape situation
he gets his arm broken and loses the
match wing is upset with gone's decision
to fight so soon he gives him a
condition that he must not practice or
study nen until he is fully recovered
wing wraps a promised thread on gone's
finger to remind him about it
kiluah tells wing how gone felt during
his match against guido explaining how
gone becomes too excited over new
challenges he adds if when quits
teaching them they'll manage to find a
new teacher or learn men by themselves
however wayne plans to continue teaching
the two
meanwhile karapika searches for a job
and is tested by the senji guild agent
who looks up employers for hunters she
creates a skull laughing face and asks
if koratpika could see it but he fails
to see it because of his lack of
knowledge about a certain technique as
he walks a mysterious man passes him on
the street and steals korop because
license without him noticing the man
later tosses a piece of stone towards
korapika in a forest which he dodges and
it hits a part of a tree and destroys it
as korapika stands wonderstruck the man
shows up and confronts him karapika then
gets angry and orders him to return his
hunter license
the man dares koratbikak to get his
license back from him
later korapika is seen down on both his
knees frustrated about his failure in
retrieving his license
the mysterious man gives back his
license tells him his name and says the
real exam is about to begin
the end of part four be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
to not miss the next part